let me show you what's going on here
we're going to pull this start from tmz
we're getting into danger zone territory
on youtube but we need to talk about
this aaron rodgers nfl teams are
recommending my covet medical regiment
to treat players what
aaron rodgers who famously took
ivermectin a concoction of other drugs
to fight covet says he's 100 sure nfl
teams are recommending his same medical
regimen to players to get over the virus
the packers superstar made the claim
tuesday on the pat mcafee show insisting
that he knows for a fact teams believe
his method of staving off coronavirus
can work i do know behind the scenes
this is 100 true there are many teams
who are using who are recommending a lot
of the same treatments that i got for
their players as we reported roger said
after he contracted chronovirus in
november that he used a combination of
drugs similar to joe rogan to recover
from the virus quickly i'm going to tell
you this and we always say it
i don't i don't care for aaron rodgers's
medical advice i do find his opinions on
how he was treated interesting now if
i'm going to take action it's not going
to be because joe rogan told me to
ingest something in fact when joe rogan
said take it seriously and and try
calling this you know find another
doctor i said i'll i'll take it
seriously because i don't want to end up
in a hospital or something like that and
i found a doctor who said monoclonal
antibodies i said i know that is an eua
authorized treatment it's the regeneron
treatment i know trump got it
okay let's do it
they gave it to us they also said they
wanted to take us a bunch of other drugs
including ivermectin to which i said i
don't think i need it because the
monoclonal antibodies in my view worked
within within 12 hours i was feeling
better i was feeling like i was
recovering everything the pain was was
gone it was incredible and i said why
should i take this and they said
i your doctor have prescribed you a
series of medications and you need to
take what i prescribe and i said fine
the problem is
when when
people in the nfl are getting that same
prescription from doctors
but regular people are being told not to
not to follow their own doctor's orders
because of youtube because of cnn
because of don lemon we're gonna have
very serious problems in this country
because i will say your doctor should be
the person prescribing this to you and
then you look at what they're talking
about didn't joe rogan also say that
congress got similar treatment
something is wrong when we can't have a
conversation about what this is when
doctors are prescribing it when
high-profile institutions are reportedly
prescribing it but you're banned for
bringing it up yup and they're getting
better and everyone else is told to go
home we haven't even prioritized early
treatment and secretly the nfl so no one
finds out according to aaron rodgers is
doing the treatments that the mainstream
media the establishment the politicians
are telling you not to take and they're
not and they're not doctors exactly the
problem i have and i've tweeted about
this a lot is that these people are like
oh i drove into a parking lot and just
someone just gave me a shot and i'm like
did your doctor advise you to do did you
go and talk to a doctor talk about look
allergies maybe allergies guillain-barre
syndrome i know it's incredibly rare but
i'm wondering if what we're getting in
the vares reports could be attributed to
people who aren't getting proper advice
from medical professionals so at the
same time at youtube and all these other
platforms are like we don't want medical
misinformation i'm like did stop fouchy
didn't stop oh but fauci is the
authority so he's allowed to be wrong
and then correct himself later nah this
is a ridiculous game it's an absolutely
ridiculous game
my recommendation is to always talk to a
doctor get a second opinion we're not
medical experts
neither is youtube neither is aaron
rodgers neither is the nfl but neither
is don lemon so when you hear these
things are being prescribed by doctors
we need to be able to have conversations
about what that means
i'm just pissed about this the viewpoint
for health in in the east for example
would be say that you have a business
and you have payroll right you don't get
to the point where you're in you're in
cash flow deficits you know you don't
get to the point where you're you're
behind on paying your staff you want to
have this big cash reserve where you're
ahead of the game and you have such a
big cash reserve that if you lose a
little bit of cash it doesn't hurt your
business so the eastern philosophy of
this of health is that you get so far
ahead in your health that if you take a
little knock it's not going to impact
you the same way that if you're behind
so the western view is more reactive the
eastern view is more
proactive but even me i've had a great
run of 10 years without having any
problems i'll never make a video on that
no way and you think people like lebron
james and tom brady who know this you
think that they're not aware of it and
they have to make a decision do i want
to speak up you know lebron kind of had
his little spider-man meme where that's
his way of getting it out
about that
tom tom's just like oh yeah i did it i
mean
so the point being is like
we'd
imagine a system where somebody as
famous and powerful as lebron james or
tom brady
might even feel uncomfortable to give
their actual opinion about these things
somebody like aaron rodgers he just kind
of old school he's like well you know
like he doesn't even know what's going
on so he just speaking like old school
he doesn't even know the change in
culture that's happened um and people
like aaron rodgers that are more and
more old school there's going to be less
and less of them as time goes on unless
things change yeah the establishment
treatment for this is the vaccine we
also have to understand that
not a treatment a preventative yeah the
establishment's answer to all of this is
the vaccine right it's their bottom line
there's vaccine mandates within the nfl
within the nba which also should be
sparking a lot of questions like okay
they're they're all vaccinated what's
really going on here when they're still
getting sick here and they're
professional athletes in the top of
their health that should be a question
that we should at least be able to kind
of even talk about and conceive i'll i
want to make sure i say this too look
aaron rodgers could be wrong i'm not
going to pretend that just because he
said something is definitive we would
need to do some some fact checking and
get some confirmation it's very
difficult i would also like to bring up
though um we just broke a record in the
united states for a 24-hour period of of
of coveted cases being reported new york
city overwhelming and we've had people
guests on the show from new york tell us
like yeah everybody they know they got
it and it was bad and so
i don't know
i'm not a doctor i'm not a scientist
don't work for pfizer but i do have some
questions about what's happening with
the with the the majority of new yorkers
who are vaccinated but still getting
sick
that can't be a breakthrough case
anymore can it could it just be that the
vaccine isn't stopping the variance at
all well again we don't know a lot of
this because a lot of the data is being
hidden away from us the cdc director
just announced after major corporations
asked her to to to stop the quarantine
from 10 days to five days she just came
out on cnn today and said quote it
really had a lot to do with what we
thought people would be able to tolerate
explaining her decision to why she
shortened the quarantine time after
major corporations asked her to do so
that's not science that's not that's not
anything definitive that actually might
help people or not help people
what made you come down to this decision
what we're going to tolerate there's a
lot of implications behind those words
i'm so done
with the the the social media guidelines
or whatever because they're out of date
they make no sense they they make no
sense at all the the science has changed
so often and so quickly and then changed
again that i don't even know what the
rules are at this point it's like can we
talk about
one of the most famous quarterbacks in
the world saying what the nfl is doing
and joe rogan no idea literally no idea
so i'm just waiting for that banhammer
any moment because they're just like
someone at youtube i'll tell you what's
going to happen because we've seen it to
other people
crowder cites the cdc strike
he was reading the cdc uh who was it um
this there was a cdc article that was
labeled fake news on facebook do you
guys remember that
none of this it's it's look maybe just
the system is imploding maybe there at
some point when we had all these
different when we had like five
different channels and all the news came
from these very specific sources it was
easy to control the narrative
now there's no controlling it it's just
smaller tribes throwing mud at each
other and youtube is like they've got a
lot of power and so like we're banning
all of this meanwhile the nfl is doing
this it's like i don't even know i don't
even know how you define what's
mainstream anymore
he's a celebrity famous no idea no idea
i don't think so i think we fractured at
such an extreme degree nothing is making
sense yeah what do you make sense of it
like what's your sense of it owen how do
you make sense of all this
from your like perspective understanding
the social dynamics anything that i any
anything that i make an argument i've
you've heard of the idea of a straw man
argument okay so a strawberry argument
is where you attack the weakest possible
position of that argument okay and
you've probably had that done on you tim
i bet you you've had that done oh yeah
where somebody like what you say we like
to steal a man yeah
so so you know what it feels like to
have somebody completely cut you out of
context make you take jokes that you
said that you you know didn't even mean
um turn you into a cartoon character i
mean look what's happened to alex you
mentioned alex jones before who i've
learned about from your show and it's
like look at what's been done to him
it's completely insane
and it doesn't mean he's perfect all the
time but look at how they cut them out
of context they'll cut people out of
context so what i do is i try to do the
courtesy of somebody who i disagree with
i try to do the steel man argument for
what they're doing so if you look at
something like censorship i ask myself
okay what is the steel man argument for
that much of a violation of the first
amendment but but it's not doing them
courtesy it's for you okay if if if you
know everyone listening if you want to
truly win an argument you must argue
against their strongest position
it's easy to try and argue against the
weak position but it also looks like
makes you look weak like i don't know if
you guys saw that video of madison
cawthorne punching the tree
you see that one there's there i think
it's medicine thorn like the left likes
playing it all the time it shows him
punching a tree that's rotted out and
i'm like you guys don't look strong for
making fun of a dude like making fun of
this dude you know what i mean you're
going after possibly the weakest
possible thing it's nothing to do with
his political arguments it does not make
it look like they have anything
substantive to say because they're
making fun of making fun of a video of
him punching a tree i'm like what does
that tree have to do with my taxes
okay so so what is the strongest
possible version you know for example
with what's happened in 2020
of the need to censor so they would say
things like misinformation so what if
somebody who's very very charismatic
right human beings do respond to
charisma we respond to who's the most
certain of themselves right and then you
know they're one of the big arguments
for censorship is they say freedom of
speech is not freedom of reach so yes
you have your free speech to do in your
basement but you know you shouldn't have
that amp
the big tech doesn't owe that to you to
amplify that that's what they would say
right so then imagine a world where big
tech didn't censor
and then all of a sudden um some super
charismatic person is like you know take
the pear you just eat a pair and then
everyone's like pear pear pear it's like
pear pear pear so it's kind of coming
from a mindset
that
the average person is is too
naive and dumb
not to fall in with somebody who's very
charismatic and so what that tells me if
you value the first amendment is you've
got to start saying to yourself well
why is it that people's like people are
being framed as stupid people are being
framed as naive and what would it take
to get our population to a point where
they are capable of seeing multiple
different arguments they're not going to
pay pay repair pair like what does it
take to get to that point what do we
have to change in our education system
to get to that point because the
ultimate answer could never be getting
rid of the first amendment that's not
the answer right but if the count if the
steel man argument is what about the
pair guy it's going to destroy the world
well if that's the counter argument then
what would be
you know our response back to that you
know we need to teach more critical
thinking um we need to teach people how
to
have
the ability to look at multiple
different sources of information and to
parse through it and to see what is
accurate there's a couple really uh good
ways to look at this
when covet happens i say okay
if i want to go out to eat there's a
risk we got covet i know how bad it is
there's a risk i'm willing to accept
certain risks to have my freedom and i
would never tell you
not to go out to eat because i'm scared
the other side of this are the people
who live in big cities who are like i'm
scared so you shouldn't be able to go
out and get food the the two different
factions are basically are you willing
are you demanding someone else take
action for you or are you willing to
take action for yourself and to protect
others you know what i mean
yeah it's um what i'll be on the street
so i'm i live in hollywood right in los
angeles and i'll be on the street and if
i don't have a mask on you'll hear
people shrieking out them like put on
your mask and you can almost tell it's
somebody who's never had status before
and they finally have the ability like
they've always wished like that day is
coming when i'm gonna get to yell at
people and put them in their place right
you can almost feel it in their nervous
system that they're not used to being
able to do that and they finally get to
write up on you say put that on right
now and they haven't done the research
they don't have
their opinion is not based on any real
critical thinking but they've just got
that big moment
you know just just to make a problem and
so on and so forth and the thing that it
did to me living in la um was that it
alienated me
from los angeles in a great way because
being around so many people that don't
have critical thinking and that just
kind of go along with that i found it to
be terrifying and it got to the point
that even with my children i started
just traveling the country and bringing
my kids outside into montana you know
where there's grizzly bears and teaching
them how to manage themselves around
wildlife and teach them critical
thinking because i'm terrified that
there's been a breach in the social
contract i just believe that you know
the people who we could normally look up
to and just say okay they've got our
best interest there's been a breach in
that and so now i've got to train my
children like hey think for yourself
think for yourself think for yourself be
adventurous don't be afraid don't fall
into safetyism and i've got to train
them on that um and i also think that
that when you start using collective
action
for things that are maybe a little
heavy-handed in overreach what it does
is it takes future situations that we
might need collective action like in
that movie don't look up we may need
collective action right but if you're
gonna be the boy who cries wolf about
any little thing then someday when we
need collective action we're not gonna
trust them and so that's creating just
this total that's that that point is
actually made in the film what i uh what
i really liked about don't look up is as
much as i felt it was very lefty
perspective is that they they
they didn't
i'll put this way some of the arguments
they made were steel man arguments so
the minor spoiler alert just want to
make sure everybody hears this before i
say this next point it's not a big plot
point but there's a point in the film
where the president basically says great
like hole in the ozone you know climate
change plagues nuclear war terror we've
heard it all before prove it
and i was like
we're supposed to be rooting for these
scientists who are just like trust this
this picture we have and i'm like that's
actually not a bad point the idea that
the entire world would react and take
collective action based on a handful of
people who are trying to assert their
right when when we are a decentralized
power structure it's not so simple yeah
it was a good movie chris i told you so
but anyway joe rogan made a very good
point i tweeted out this video and it's
him pretty much saying you know i worked
on my health almost my entire life i've
taken supplements i worked out i've
taken care of myself and then you have
literally obese people that have never
taken responsibility for themselves have
never taken care of their body who are
telling me that i need to do a certain
thing for them when they're not the ones
that are taking care of themselves this
is absolutely absurd he had other uh
more kind of french words for it but but
he makes a very good point because a lot
of these people who are screaming at you
that are telling you what to do are some
of the people who haven't taken their
responsibility who haven't taken that
important role in their life and said
okay this is something that i need to
critically think about this is not
something that is gonna going to go away
if everyone does what i say or if
everyone wears a mask it's not it's
going to go away once you start taking
care of yourself we start worrying about
the terrain we start talking about the
treatments and again what would happen
here with aaron rodgers we got to
support him that's why i put his jersey
behind me there he's getting attacked by
a lot of corporate media institutions so
it's kyrie irving he's coming back to
the nba in a very poetic way
but but
there's so many of these individuals
they deserve our support because they're
actually speaking out against these
larger truths when a lot of people are
afraid to do so or they're just
screaming
just nonsense muffled nonsense behind
their masks i have a question thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time